I would say the owners co-op program
made it possible for me to have the
career I have now I really was an
electrical engineer and that's all I was
when I got out of undergraduate school I
don't think I would have been able to
succeed in what's essentially a software
career had I not done the honors co-op
program this honors call program really
benefited me professionally because I
was able to get some exposure to what
the business world is like and found out
that's something I'd like to do and
subsequently at least a Xerox I was able
to move away from an engineering career
path to move into the strategic business
office the almost co-op program had a
very deep impact on my professional
development because it really gave me
the skills that I need to do my job
today there's no longer pure engineering
but a much broader sense follow business
management I as a hiring manager and and
looking for talent when I see a Stanford
master's degree on that resume first of
all I know what it means to get one and
I actually put on my resume not only
that I got my master's degree but I also
did it during the time when I was
working